Chad, I understand you moved to Los Angeles
in 1995?
1996.
Do you think you worker hard now than you
did in 1996?
Or is it the same but a different type of
working at it?
It’s a different type of working at it.
Like I said, when I first moved here I had
blinders on and you don’t realize what you’re
getting into, what this means.
And so I worked very hard to break into the
business and I got lucky that it happened
at a very early age.
You have to work just as hard, if not harder,
once you do get some success.
I think you have to keep working to hopefully
keep that success although this business is
up and down and it doesn’t seem to be anywhere
in between.
At least for me it seems like you have those
good years and then you have years where you
don’t work.
You have to ride it out.
A lot of actors will ask “What do you suggest?
What’s your advice?”
And what I say is “Persistence is key.
Don’t leave.”
“Be the last one standing” is what my
acting coach said to me.
Be the last one standing.
So you have to.
Don’t give up because if you give up that
might have been the next day where you got
that audition that is going to change your
life.
So if it’s who you are, don’t give up.
You can’t.
As much as you might want to….as much as
I have days where I’m like “Aaaargh!”
I just want to say “Peace Out” and run
and go the other way but then I would be miserable
because it is who I am.
I know we talked about this a long time ago
in 2012 where you said you knew that this
was the choice you were going to make.
Maybe you can revisit this for us where…do
you remember the exact moment where you said
to yourself This Is What I Want!
Where you weren’t going to be o.k.
if you said to yourself “You know what,
why don’t I get a job” or go back to a
vocational school and try to get a desk job
or something?
When did you know that this was for you?
I knew….I knew in high school that is what
I wanted to do at a very early age.
Nobody was going to tell me differently.
You know, looking back I don’t think I’m…I’m
not the guy to sit behind a desk at an office.
Not that there is anything wrong with that.
It’s just not who I am.
I’m kind of used to the uncertainty now
and sort of crazy off life it is to be an
actor.
It’s not a regular thing.
There is no certainty in this business.
There is mostly uncertainty.
So you kind of have to roll with that.
Interesting….so being comfortable with being
uncomfortable?
Exactly.
Yes.
It’s being comfortable with being uncomfortable
which is pretty much all the time.
And then you’ll have a couple great months
where you work and you go on location.
The last movie I did, I went to Bulgaria for
a month and a half and got to work with Antonio
Banderas and Sir Ben Kingsley.
It was amazing.
And then you return and it’s back to reality.
So…[laughs] it’s a very weird business.
It changes on a dime and that is what I love
about it!
You just never know.
Question for the viewers.
Tell us about the moment you decided to pursue
an entertainment career.